Io sono di un'età
in cui partecipare a un Ted non è
propriamente semplice
non ne conosco le dinamiche non sono
avanti con la tecnologia non ho memoria
insieme siamo quei vecchi rintronati che
al Ted farebbero bene partecipare non
andare a fare gli speaker
però sono rimasto fortemente sedotto dal
tema di questo Ted e all'invito che mi è
venuto da un amico non ho potuto dire di
no quindi la sfida è provarci io parlo a
braccio non sono più in grado di
ricordare un discorso così ben
articolato come hanno fatto gli altri
relatori Tutti bravissimi impressionato
dalla loro bravura e lo faccio perché
posso raccontare una storia io posso
raccontare una storia che riguarda tutti
quanti noi la cucina italiana la cucina
più buona del mondo
è un patrimonio questo che più che
demandarlo ai grandi chef che siamo
abituati a vedere in televisione sempre
di più e che raccontano
spettacolo rispetto alla cucina
questo patrimonio incommensurabile e
invece nelle nostre famiglie nelle
nostre case
ciascuna delle nostre mamme
zie nonne noi uomini appassionati di
cucina che ci occupiamo di portare a
tavola il risultato del nostro lavoro
appassionato siamo i veri detentori di
questo primato non a caso una delle
ultime ricerche commissionate al Censis
da casa Artusi ha rilevato che almeno il
78% degli italiani in cucina in casa
e di questi il 45% sono giovani fra i 25
e i 35 anni quasi tutti lo fanno con
passione
pochissimo subiscono il
peso di dover cucinare per la famiglia
Insomma è tanta roba Tanta roba di cui
dovremmo andare ieri tanta roba che
dovremmo sapere valorizzare e ci si
chiede qualche volta se questo avviene
oppure no io sono figlio di un operaio
il mio papà era imbianchino e veniva da
una famiglia che vi do subito l'idea
quale fosse se a mio papà si chiedeva
qual era stato il momento più felice
della sua vita avrebbe risposto il
servizio militare
perché lui lì ha avuto per la prima
volta un paio di scarpe ai piedi
e quando si è congedato d'inverno ha
portato a casa un cappotto che era il
bene Preziosissimo per i suoi quattro
fratelli con i quali l'ha diviso
in questa famiglia povera si mangiava si
cucinava tutti i giorni il poco che
c'era e si faceva cucina semplice non
povera ma si faceva cucina e rispetto al
resto del mondo e noi poi il mondo
Abbiamo imparato a conoscerlo nel tempo
abbiamo capito che in questa cucina
c'era un valore fondamentale che era il
valore di uno spirito acquisito con
secoli di civiltà la grande cucina
italiana è tale Innanzitutto per una
ragione territoriale questa supremazia
nel meraviglioso bacino del Mediterraneo
che permette al nostro paese di proporre
una biodiversità che non è uguale E poi
la storia la storia d'Italia una storia
di civiltà che si è sviluppata in
maniera Così
privatistica da primato così avanti a
tutti gli altri e alla quale sempre la
cucina si è collegata
quindi una cucina che possiamo
considerare di civiltà e pensate ci sono
oggi giochino fra i patrimoni materiali
dell'Unesco di tutto la gastronomia
francese la dieta mediterranea
probabilmente una quantità infinita di
piatti di cui sa quale paese del mondo
ma la cucina italiana non è patrimonio
dell'umanità
rimanga nostro quanto meno e Facciamo di
tutto per tutelarla tutela che non
avviene non avviene perché noi abbiamo
quelli che dovrebbero essere gli
ambasciatori della cucina italiana nel
mondo i cuochi che appena diventano un
poco bravi Si fanno chiamare chef
Hanno smesso di essere italiani hanno
dimenticato la storia Hanno dimenticato
la tradizione Hanno dimenticato la
cultura che ha generato la loro capacità
e vanno a scimmiottare cose che messe su
un tavolo della globalizzazione con
tutta probabilità Ci vedrebbero perdenti
rispetto a qualunque altro paese del
mondo Allora la cucina italiana
tradizionale quella che secondo il mio
amico grande filosofo Tullio Gregory era
la cucina da salvaguardare da tutelare
perché il recante con sé una quantità di
valori infiniti che legava il l'italiano
perfino alla divinità e la cucina alla
quale noi di più dovremmo fare
riferimento ed è quella che a mio parere
ancora oggi se salvaguardata se presa in
considerazione nonostante l'inflazione
di attività che vivono della
cucina e della gastronomia potrebbero
darci Questa è una grande quantità di
opportunità
e le opportunità che vengono dalla
cucina vengono dai loro professionisti
dai grandi protagonisti della cucina
italiana che non sono chef o cuochi
traditori ma sono i piccoli bottegai il
salumiere il pescivendolo il panettiere
il gelataio il pastaio quelle attività
meravigliose che fino a poco tempo fa
riempivano di profumi i vicoli delle
nostre città e che oggi tendono a
sparire
Ecco io ho visto in controluce questa
tematica e in controluce Mi sono
appassionato all'idea che questa fosse
una categoria da salvaguardare gli
artigiani del gusto e Gli ho inventato
un progetto che mettendolo tutti insieme
ha generato questo
Ecco un progettino da 12 milioni e mezzo
di persone l'anno che è nato nel 2014 si
è sviluppato in maniera incredibile e
continuo a crescere presto apriremo a
Melbourne probabilmente a Londra poi a
Parigi Insomma l'ortolano il macellaio
il gastronomo che si perde dalle città e
che trova altra collocazione E allora la
cucina italiana è ancora un'opportunità
tutta da scoprire poi ho collegato a
questo un altro grande patrimonio che ci
appartiene che è l'arte la cultura in
generale è una delle carte vincenti del
nostro paese da sempre noi all'interno
di Mercato Centrale produciamo grandi
progetti d'arte non comuni per
un'attività di ristorazione un'attività
che serve cibo non comune vuol dire che
lo facciamo con artisti del calibro di
Daniel buren di Michelangelo pistoletto
delle grandi protagonisti
dell'architettura
giochiamo con le istituzioni Quando
presentano grandi mostre d'arte come
Picasso Marina Abramovic e nel mercato
componiamo colazioni d'arte Life Music
lezioni di musica valorizziamo Il
folclore e chi più ne ha più ne metta
Insomma Mercato Centrale è la creatura
che si è creata all'interno
ho perso le slide
era erano i miei artigiani me li sono
portati dietro per farmi aiutare a
salutarvi hanno superato
l'intoppo del della slide ma comunque
Ecco con i miei artigiani anche io vi
saluto e vi ringrazio per l'attenzione